FORCED MORE REFUGEES INTO
NEIGHBORING CHAD.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE BY FAR NOW
FOR SUDAN IS THE NILE DAM
DISPUTE, A CONFLICT INVOLVING
THREE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE NILE'S WATERS,
WITH SUDAN CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF A DECADE LONG SITUATION.
I WANTED TO BREAK IT DOWN PIECE
BY PIECE.
THE RIVER NILE HAS BEEN A
BACKBONE OF CIVILIZATION FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
SEVERAL COUNTRIES IN AFRICA RELY
ON IT AS A KEY WATER SOURCE, BUT
IT HAS ALSO BEEN A SOURCE OF
TENSION.
THOSE TENSIONS REACHED A BOILING
POINT RECENTLY, PARTICULARLY
BETWEEN EGYPT, SUDAN, ETHIOPIA.
HERE IS WHY.
IN 2011, THEY BUILT A HUGE DAM
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE ELECTRICITY
TO MORE OF ITS CITIZENS.
THIS WAS A HUGE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT.
IT COST ABOUT $4 BILLION AND WAS
SET TO BE AFRICA'S LARGEST
HYDROELECTRIC POWER DAM.
ETHIOPIA WANTS THAT RESERVOIR
FILLED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
GEN
GENERATE MAXIMUM ELECTRICITY,
BUT THEIR NEIGHBORS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN.
EGYPT RELIES ON THE NILE FOR ALL
ITS DRINKING WATER, ALL ITS
IRRIGATION.
THEY BELIEVE THIS DAM WILL
DRASTICALLY REDUCE WATER
SUPPLIES.
SUDAN ON THE OTHER HAND IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE DAM SAFETY AND
WHETHER OR NOT THE WATER FLOW
WILL IMPACT THEIR OWN DAMS,
THEIR OWN WATER STATIONS.
BOTH COUNTRIES ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE DAM GIVING ETHIOPIA TOO
MUCH, AND FLOWS NORTH THROUGH
SUDAN, MERGES WITH THE WHITE
NILE BEFORE GOING INTO EGYPT.
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH
NEGOTIATION, SO MUCH DEBATE, AND
NO RESOLUTION.
ETHIOPIA IS GOING AHEAD BUILDING
THE DAM, THEY'RE STILL FILLING
THE RESERVOIR WITH WATER AS
WELL.
SOME FEEL THE POSSIBILITY OF
MILITARY CONFLICT AS A RESULT.
TIME FOR ZAIN'S EXCHANGE.
WE TAKE A LOOK WHAT'S AT STAKE
FOR SUDAN IN THE DISPUTE OVER
THE NILE DAM.
THREE COUNTRIES INVOLVED ARE
DEADLOCKED OVER WHAT COMES NEXT.
EARLIER I SPOKE WITH THE PRIME
MINISTER AND BEGAN BY ASKING HIM
IF HE BELIEVES EGYPT'S THREAT TO
GO TO WAR.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED
TO THE DAM ARE VERY SERIOUS.
AND I THINK WHEN THE PRESIDENT
MADE THAT STATEMENT, HE WOULD
LIKE, LIKE US, TO EXPRESS TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS ISSUE.
IT IS TIME BOUND.
IT IS LINKED TO THE SAFETY,
SECURITY, OF MILLIONS OF OUR
PEOPLE IN SUDAN AND EGYPT.
I THINK WE WOULD LIKE THE REST
OF THE WORLD TO UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVITY OF THE SITUATION AND TO
THE POINT THAT THE ISSUES THAT
ARE RELATED ARE SOLO.
WE CAN EASILY RESOLVE THEM IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS.
SO ALSO I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIS DISSOLVE WITHIN THE
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
>> SPEAKING OF THE RESOLUTION,
YOUR GOVERNMENT TALKED ABOUT
GETTING INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS
AND MEDIATORS TO INTERVENE,
PERHAPS SOME INTERVENTION FROM
U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL.
OBVIOUSLY THE AU HOSTED TALKS,
GETTING MORE COOPERATION FROM
THE U.S., THE U.N., THE EU AS
WELL.
ETHIOPIA SAYS THIS IS AN AFRICAN
PROBLEM AND IT SHOULD BE SOLVED
BY AFRICAN LEADERS ONLY.
DO THEY HAVE A POINT?
>> YOU KNOW, WE ARE THE FIRST TO
PROPOSE THE MODEL OF AFRICAN
SOLUTIONS FOR AFRICAN PROBLEMS.
AU IS OUR PREMIER INSTITUTION.
WE RESPECT IT.
WHAT WE PROPOSE IS TO ADD TO THE
ROLE OF THE AU, THE MEDIATORS
WHO ARE THERE, THEY'RE OBSERVING
THE PROCESS WITH US THE LAST
YEAR OR SO.
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE THEM TO THE
ROLE FROM OBSERVER PASSIVELY TO
OPERATE AS MEDIATORS WHO COULD
HELP US REACH AN AGREEMENT AND
REACH IT SOON.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, PRIME
MINISTER.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS SUDAN WAS
PERFECTLY HAPPY TO GO ABOUT, FOR
ETHIOPIA TO GO ABOUT BUILDING
THE DAM.
SUDAN HAD SUPPORTED THE IDEA
THAT ETHIOPIA NEEDED A WAY OF
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY FOR MORE
CITIZENS.
NOW IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THERE'S A
SUDDEN ABOUT CHANGE IN SUPPORT.
WHAT BROUGHT THAT ABOUT?
>> YES, THE DAM BRINGS A LOT OF
BENEFITS, BUT FOR THESE BENEFITS
TO MATERIALIZE, WE HAVE TO REACH
A BINDING AGREEMENT THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO PLAN OUR LIFE, TO BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THE WATER THAT'S
COMING FROM THE DAM IN A WAY
THAT WILL ALLOW AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION AND LIVELIHOOD.
WITHOUT THAT AGREEMENT, WE WOULD
ALWAYS BE AT THE MERCY OF
ETHIOPIA TO GIVE IT TODAY AND
CLOSE IT TOMORROW.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR A
BINDING AGREEMENT WITHIN
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
>> TENSIONS OVER THE DAM ARE NOT
THE ONLY REASON WHY SUDAN AND
ETHIOPIA ARE AT LOGGER HEADS
NOW.
THERE'S ALSO ISSUES WHEN IT
COMES TO DISPUTED BORDERS.
THERE ARE BORDER CLASHES BETWEEN
ETHIOPIA AND SUDAN HAPPENING
NOW.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT WON'T
LEAD TO WAR EITHER?
>> SUDAN BORDERS SEVERAL
COUNTRIES.
THE ONLY BORDER AREA AMONG THE
SEVERAL COUNTRIES THAT HAS NO
DISPUTE WHICH WAS RESOLVED YEARS
BACK, BACK TO 1902.
WE HAD AN AGREEMENT THAT LED US
TO THE BOARDERS ON THE MAP AND
ON THE GROUND, SUCCESSIVE
GOVERNMENTS -- WE DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY IS IT SUDDENLY AN
ISSUE.
IN FACT, WE HAD ESTABLISHED A
JOINED BORDER COMMITTEE THAT MET
TWICE AT LEAST IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS, WE WERE MOVING FORWARD
TO RESOLVE THIS.
THERE'S ROOM FOR RESOLVING THIS
PEACEFULLY.
>> ANOTHER QUESTION, I WANT TO
PIVOT SLIGHTLY, ISRAEL.
SUDAN NORMALIZED RELATIONS WITH
ISRAEL.
THE PALESTINIANS SOMEWHAT FELT
BETRAYED BY THAT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PALESTINIAN RESPONSE TO SUDAN'S
NORMALIZATION WITH RELATIONS
WITH ISRAEL?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS GREAT
REVOLUTION OF SUDAN WHICH
BROUGHT THE DICTATORSHIP --
WE'VE DOPTD A FOREIGN POLICY
TRANSFORMED SUDAN INTO A COUNTRY
THAT IS AT PEACE WITH ITSELF,
WITH ITS NEIGHBORS, AND ALL
THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE OF
NORMALIZATION WITH ISRAEL,
NORMALIZATION IS NOT AN EVENT.
IT IS A PROCESS.
WE HAVE STARTED THIS, BUT THE
FINAL SAY WOULD BE LEFT TO THE
PEOPLE THROUGH THEIR
INSTITUTIONS.
>> PRIME MINISTER, YOU TALKED
ABOUT SORT OF SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT SUDAN HAS MADE,
OBVIOUSLY TRANSITIONING FROM
DICTATORSHIP TO DEMOCRACY, BEING
REMOVED AS STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM, BEING NOW OPEN TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD, HAVING A
RELATIONSHIP AND DIALOGUE WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
WHAT DO YOU HOPE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, WHAT
BENEFITS DO YOU HOPE IT BRINGS
TO SUDAN IN THE LONG TERM?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS, YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SUDAN IS PASSING THROUGH
MULTIPLE TRANSITIONS.
FROM CONFLICT AND WARS TO PEACE,
FROM DICTATORSHIP TO DEMOCRACY,
FROM ISOLATION TO RELINKING TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND ALSO
FROM COLLAPSING THE ECONOMY TO
PROSPERITY.
OPENING UP TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD WILL OPEN SUDAN FOR
INVESTMENT AND AS YOU KNOW, OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF, BEEN
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
UNITED STATES, REMOVAL OF SUDAN
FROM THE LIST OF STATES
SPON
SPONSORING TERRORISM.
IT IS A GAME CHANGER.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT OMARAL
BASHIR, THE DICTATE OR THAT
RULED SUDAN MANY YEARS, ACCUSED
OF WAR CRIMES, VIOLENCE, MASS
KILLINGS THAT LED TO THE DEATH
OF 300,000 SUDANESE PEOPLE
DURING THE CONFLICT IN DARFUR.
ARE YOU COMMITTED AT THIS POINT,
PRIME MINISTER, TO MAKING SURE
THAT OMAR AL BASHIR IS HANDED TO
THE INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL COURT
TO FACE JUSTICE?
>> YOU KNOW, THE THREE SLOGANS
OF THIS REVOLUTION WHY JUSTICE,
FREEDOM, AND EQUALITY, AND I
THINK WE WILL NOT REST UNTIL WE
SEE JUSTICE BEING SERVED TO THE
UTMOST SATISFACTION OF THE
VICTIMS' FAMILIES.
WE HAVE BEEN IN DIRECT TALKS
WITH THE ICC, PROSECUTOR CAME TO
VISIT US.
SHE'S COMING NEXT MONTH TO VISIT
US AGAIN.
AND WE ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THEM.
WE ARE VERY DETERMINED THAT
JUSTICE WILL BE SERVED AND TO
THE SATISFACTION OF OUR
FAMILIES' VICTIMS, WE WILL DO
ANYTHING THAT WILL LEAD US TO
THAT SATISFACTION AND THA